I joined a band at you know in seventh
grade was in the same band through
Junior High in high school uh then in
college uh the band finally broke up and
that's when I met Daryl I just you know
the way I looked at it is people never
really stopped clapping
so I kept doing it what you probably
told the story but do you remember the
day you met Daryl and you said something
clicked
yeah I remember exactly we were he had a
group called the temp Tunes I had a
group called The Masters we both had
singles out it was in the summer of 1967
uh in Philadelphia there was they were
both being played on the same radio
stations so I was aware of him he was
aware of me
um we were invited independently to go
to this record hop which was what DJ's
you know a teenage dance basically uh
and while we were waiting backstage
there was a gang fight and so broke out
in the in the in the crowd and so his
band and my band we went in a service
elevator down to the street and that's
how we met
um and then we just we were both going
to Temple University
um we kept seeing each other around uh
then he lost the guitar player my band
broke up too the guys got drafted to
Vietnam and I joined his group as a
guitar player that group broke up and he
and I started hanging out jeez just by
happenstance that elevator you know if
that fight didn't break out you probably
wouldn't have met that night there'd be
no Hall and Oates yeah well you know a
lot of things happened I mean if I
wouldn't have picked Temple University
you'd go to college I mean I had a bunch
of other colleges I was looking at
um you know it was just hey things you
never know how things are going to work
out who was the more outgoing of the two
you when you met were you both kind of
outgoing Ladies Man like kind of like
just having fun everything was simple
then
everything was simple then that's for
sure uh it's not the same as it is now
that's for sure uh no you know we were
hippies you know we just kind of tripped
around and did things and that
Philadelphia had this little hippie
Community downtown and we were part of
that and so you know we I was playing in
a blues band Daryl was doing some studio
work and then eventually he played in a
bar band uh and none of the things that
we did independently seemed to click and
then the crazy part is is that after I
graduated from college in night the
spring of 1970. I wanted to go to Europe
so I had a motorcycle and I had a few
other things I sold I got I think I had
400 bucks and I had a backpack and a
guitar and I went to Europe and and I
hitchhiked around Europe for four months
and during that time I sublet my
apartment to Daryl's sister and her
boyfriend
and so when I got back in October
um after being gone for four months I
went to my apartment and there was a
padlock on the door because they didn't
pay the rent and I had nowhere to go so
Daryl was living you know not very close
a few blocks away so I just
put my backpack and guitar back on walk
down the street knocked on his door and
said hey man your sister kind of screwed
me up here I got nowhere to live he said
he said oh don't worry about it why
don't you just go upstairs and sleep on
the couch up there and so I went up to
the top floor where by the way where his
electric piano was and then
um I slept on the fold-out couch and
he'd come up he'd start playing piano
I'd pull out my guitar and we start next
thing you know we were writing songs and
there you go it was that easy it was
that just messing around and all of a
sudden we had known we had known each
other for three years prior to that but
we hadn't really worked together
and what did you know you had something
special or was it just two guys having a
good time no no in fact we we made a
First recording at the Temple University
Radio Studio because we could get in for
free and we did this tape of a song that
we wrote it was so bad it was horrible
what was it what was it called oh it was
some stupid
hippie dip [ __ ] so and and um
and we both looked at each other when
let's just hang out this this is never
going to work wow because his his voice
was very high and pristine my voice was
kind of you know low and rough and it
just it sounded horrible and little by
little you know I guess I guess I don't
know what you know he he went this way
and I went this way and we kind of
figured out a way of singing together
and what was the first song that you
could go holy [ __ ] you know this is
better than that recording we did at
Temple University this is so cool we had
we had you know the first album we did
was just a collection of stuff that
songs that I had songs that he had it
wasn't really conceived like a record
but we we got a contract so we made the
record for Atlantic Records and it was
really the second album The Abandoned
luncheonette where it really came
together
um and that's what she's gone she's gone
was on that sort of that album and that
that song was you know I call that the
perfect storm that's uh the perfect
creative storm but